selim vous êtes coach en séduction et
vous publiez sur amazon un ebook qui
cartonne il est numéro un des ventes
et ça s'appelle la méthode rendez vous
comment aborder et séduire les femmes de
manière naturelle et respectueuse on est
en plein dans l'ère du temps donc numéro
1 des ventes dans la catégorie
psychologie de la communication et
première question évidemment comment
vous est venue l'idée de ce livre céline
ça fait dix ans que je suis coach en
séduction et on voit que ça n'évolue pas
les oreilles que je coache ils ont
toujours ce même souci ils sont trop
timides ils n'osent pas y aller ils
n'ont pas confiance en eux donc je me
suis dit ok on va écrire un nouveau
livre à nouveau mais cette fois ci
vraiment sur la méthode rdv donc rassuré
divertir valoriser c'est très très
simple c'est pour les aider à se dire à
mme en fait j'ai des trucs à raconter et
je peux le faire et surtout parce que
parfois ils ont ils ont peur quoi ils
ont peur de quoi de passe qui sont à la
fois timide mais ils ont peur d'être mal
reçue par les jeunes femmes à l'ère post
me tout on va dire ça on va dire que
même si elles ont des choses à raconter
faire le premier pas c'est compliqué
c'est se dire waouh si elle a quelqu'un
ciel moreau calcia l'humilie devant tout
le monde si je ne trouve pas les mots et
si méchant que ça enfin oui on n'avait
pas ce point là c'est vrai elle est
méchante bon effectif et ça fait
d'accord il aurait évidemment beaucoup
de questions à vous poser son lit votre
livre et on va démarrer pas si beau que
vous connaissez bien oui alors c'est
l'hymne ça fait près de dix ans que je
le connais justement merci pour tes
conseils introduction le tutoie du coup
parce que ça marche
stop comment ça fonctionne mais vous
avez des envies comme ça mais vous vous
avez une fiancée oui tous les jours la
même on est d'accord là même bien sûr
même et du coup sauf qu'en disant il ya
énormément de choses qui ont changé il
faut toujours remettre le coeur un
ouvrage alors qu'est ce qui a vraiment
changé de la société depuis dix ans dix
ans là comme ça qui est pour vos leçons
là tout de suite je te dirais qu'on a
plus trop la possibilité de faire une
mauvaise première impression c'est
parfois tu peux y arriver tu peux
bégayer tu ne sais pas quoi raconter ou
alors tu peux être un tout petit peu
lourde ce qui pouvait arriver autrefois
la timidité
aujourd'hui on va se dire c'est moins
tolérée c'est un vin tolérer donc moi je
les aide les coaches et les hommes avec
qui je travaille à trouver la bonne
histoire à savoir en gros se vendre
vanté comme ans comment pardon mais vous
utilisez un terme très marketing et se
vendre donc il faut se vendre comme un
pro produits comme unis comme une
lessive non pas comme un produit comme
une lessive juste on imagine d'imaginons
vous me trouvez à votre goût et donc
vous avez envie de faire un premier pas
comment est-ce que vous conseilleriez un
jeune homme gilles devenir m'aborder de
magna j'attaquerai pas sur le travail
j'attaquerai pas sur votre renommée
j'attaquerai vraiment sur un élément en
fait de la situation on parle
d'environnement chaud ou dans les cafés
on a qu'a prôné dans un café on est
posée dans un café je suis en train de
lire mon jour la personne est en train
de lire son journal
vous lisez un truc vous faites tomber
votre cuillère ben on va rebondir là
dessus ou alors vous regardez la carte
ah je vous conseille quelque chose on
essaie de rentrer par rapport à des
observations on essaie de rentrer dans
la conversation avec une observation
vraiment et sans faire flipper parce que
parfois ça peut être quelqu'un qui a un
qatar vient comme ça dans une
conversation ça peut être voilà
dérangeur d'accord ça peut être assez
naturel assez léger c'est vraiment le
l'art de la séduction c'est quelque
chose qui est subtile on essaie de ne
pas y aller avec nos gros sabots et
c'est ça surtout qui a changé en dix ans
et que on n'est plus d'accord avec ça et
les femmes aujourd'hui vous même plus
attendre c'est ok d'accord et met donc
en gros pour vous séduire c'est à dire
juste une suite de technique il ya plus
de sentiments ils sont où les sentiments
tout ça alors non les sentiments il
arrive après est déjà la première
impression que l'essai on on va pas
confondre le sentiment et l'attirance
oui on peut rencontrer quelqu'un c'est
ma voisine de terrasses de café je la
trouve attirant je ne sait rien d'elle
et pourtant il ya des coachs et des
jeunes hommes qui arrive quand je suis
amoureux ma voisine de classe je suis
amoureux de ma collègue de bureau
non le sentiment amoureux c'est quelque
chose d'autre donc c'est pas un
enchaînement technique c on y va de
manière vulnérables on y va de manière
honnête on se dit j'ai envie de faire sa
connaissance véritablement et j'y vais
comme je suis c'est vraiment le venez
comme vous êtes
slogan d'accord c'est bien de dire deux
fois vous avez une clientèle d'hommes
qui ont entre quel âge et quel âge c'est
ce qu'ils achètent vote les livres ils
ont vous savez à peu près alors ça
malheureusement on n'a pas les chiffres
j'ai pas le détail des ventes
non ce qu'on sait c'est que il ya trois
groupes à peu près dans les hommes qui
nous lisent on a dû 18 25 ans du très
jeune donc il manque d'expérience qui a
peut-être raté le train du collège et du
lycée et qui du coup il un peu à la
traîne
on a le jeune qui revient sur le marché
25 35 ans perdu confiance en lui à la
suite d'une rupture et après on allait
divorcer en gros l'âge moyen du divorce
en france ses 42 ans et c'est pour moi
c'est ma c'est ceux avec qui je préfère
travailler parce que il faut jongler
avec la garde des enfants avec donc la
garde alternée le travail et c'est
surtout des hommes qui n'ont plus dragué
puis france 98 pas sûr que ces terres
sont assez évidents prendre cette cale
alors parce que fran clader voir et
votre livre autant vous dire ça les
intéresse au plus haut point oui
justement moi je suis en jachère depuis
98 donc rapport au fait que j'ai
vraiment du mal à pécho mais je voudrais
savoir parce qu'on est quand même 8
millions de célibataires en france
hommes femmes confondus qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire alors moi en tant que femme
j'ai envie de pêcher que je ne suis pas
fermé
j'aimerais que vous me donniez les clés
je sais que vous conseillez des hommes
mais aidez nous aussi les femmes parce
qu'il ya des femmes en galère bien sûr
ces deux là c'est la communication
globalement la séduction c'est de la
communiste par exemple à brûle pourpoint
comme ça en voyant comme francesca
qu'est-ce qui tout de suite pour vous
saute aux yeux qui pourrait rebuter un
homme qui ferait qu' il aurait ri n'ont
fait qu'augmenter ce cabanon sur la trop
belle pour certains qui n'ont sans lui
je vais partir là dessus si certains
n'ont pas assez confiance en eux une
femme très très belle se disent ok moi
dans ma tête peut-être que je vaux 5 sur
10 6 sur 17 7 sur 10
francesca elle est connue est fait de la
télé à côtoie des gens ultra connus
hanifi il ya trop de paramètres c'est ça
je serai pas au niveau donc je vous
promets que je n'ai pas payé il n'a pas
été rémunéré pousse très bien
en tout cas il fait du bien à l'ego oui
c'est sûr merci d'accord mais donc mais
donc ça c'est à elles datent de faire
les premiers pas peut-être conseillé aux
femmes de faire c'est pas forcément
faire le premier pas mais on communique
tous c'est le non verbal c'est le
langage du corps
quand on est fermé ça se voit quand on
vous dit ça et quand on se montre ouvert
quand on est souriant là il ya une
certaine invitation à venir parler moi
j'observe dans des groupes d'amis en
soirée on les voit il son 3 4 et le
groupe est très ferme et donc forcément
la fille célibataire du groupe
elle est bloquée personne ne peut venir
la route n'est pas le soir est éloigné
de cette contrée vitesse que la clé des
petites petites minutes
gilles vous aviez une dernière question
à poser bonjour monsieur je vous connais
pas mais vous vous écrivez à la page 24
la femme que vous voulez séduire vont
évaluer leur probabilité de survie et de
reproduction à la profondeur de votre
porte monnaie
est ce que vous n'avez pas écrit un
livre sexiste non heureusement bienvenue
monsieur vergès
non le lien n'est pas sexiste on part de
simplement du fait que l'homme et la
femme on est là sur terre pour se
reproduire il ya deux instinct qu'on a
tous en nous c'est la survie et la
reproduction
une fois qu'on a ça on réfléchit on se
dit ok qu'est ce que la survie et la
reproduction autrefois bon ben c'était
le mec le plus fort c'était le chef de
la tribu c'était celui qui avait les
plus longs bras pour aller cueillir les
fruits c'était celui qui communique est
le mieux pour avoir un peu le tout la
tribu avec lui pour organiser toute la
vie aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui fait qu'on
va survivre le plus dans cette société
nadine voilà continue à baisser le ratio
n'en a pas on peut tout de même séduit
avec un état grave mais c'est l'effacer
du seul cas c'est que ça va être le
physique ça va commencer par
tout le monde jean claude dusse y
tentait toujours ses vrais gens posant
point de vue s'il a des il a des
possibilités merci infiniment
je rappelle que votre appel la méthode
rang début comment aborder et séduire
les femmes de manière naturelle et
respectueuse merci